all right so the Last of Us comes with
an ending that I think will stick with
everyone long after they experience it
whether you watch the events play out in
the game of show I think that it leaves
a lasting impression due to the
situation that the two protagonists find
themselves in towards the end of the
story Joel finally reaches the fireflies
with Ellie but he discovers that in
order to make a vaccine that she has to
die Joel is someone who lost his
daughter and rather than going through
the pain of this again he decides to
murder all of the fireflies and take her
back to his brother and Jackson Joe lies
to her about what really happened and he
makes Ellie believe that everything was
all for nothing well not for nothing as
he now has a surrogate daughter and she
has the father figure that she's always
wanted in her life he tells her in the
show that writers arrived at the
hospital and though he leaves out this
detail in the game he makes a believe
that they've given up on finding a cure
the gaming show also closed out on the
exact same moment with Ali asking Joel
to swear that everything he said is true
swear to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true
[Music]
I swear
okay
now was Joel right or wrong well firstly
I think we have to discuss the two sides
of the argument and how Marlene and Joel
are actually pretty similar Bell who are
tasked with guarding Ellie and they made
a promise to protect her both knew she
was immune and both were told there was
a way to manufacture a cure from her
however where they differentiate is that
Joel's not willing to kill for this or
as Marlene is Joel is a lone wolf who's
seen the worst in humanity and he's been
a closed Buck since the death of his
daughter he knows what it's like to lose
a child and doesn't think that it's
worth sacrificing a kid like this on a
cause Moline on the other hand is
looking at the greater good or as Jill
tended to work on his own she's been
part of a group she sees Ellie's
immunity as something that could help
humanity and believes in the best of us
as the collective Joel believes in the
best of us as individuals and he refuses
to give up the needs of the few to help
the needs of the many a Joel throughout
the series in game was a very closed off
man who refused to open up to anyone
because he he knew what true loss was as
a parent I can't imagine how painful it
would be losing a child and going off
what I've heard from other people it's
the most difficult thing you can go
through he simply refuses to do this
again and Views taking Ali to the
fireflies as throwing her to the Wolves
it's safe to say that Ali you also
brought something out of him that he
thought was long gone throughout the
series in game we see Joel glancing at
his watch from time to time and this is
a reminder of the life he had with Sarah
given to him as a birthday present it
broke during the fall in which he was
shot and since then it's been frozen in
time like he has however he started to
grow with Ellie or as he refused to talk
about his past we see him opening up
about it in episode 9. now they do
things differently in the episode and
game but they carry the same meaning in
the game during the Jackson chapter
Tommy tried to give him a photo of him
and Sarah but he refused to acknowledge
it we learned that Ellie ended up
stealing this and taking it on their
Journey she presented it to him at the
end and he finally ignored knowledge
that you can't outrun your past in the
show he says that Ellie has helped them
to move on finally and to put it plainly
he doesn't want to go through this again
Joel knows how bad that loss like that
can be and also what it can do to a
person little is known about the 20
years between outbreak day and when we
catch him in Boston but we do know that
bad things happened due to what he says
about Brian he's clearly killed people
like him before and he's run through the
hospital shows just how merciless he is
he's very much sparing himself from
becoming this person again or something
even worse going through this twice in
one lifetime would completely break him
and he sees Ali as a way out of the
darkness the Firefly saying is of course
luck for the light and this is very much
what Ellie represents Sarah's ghost
still haunts him and in many ways even
just seeing a woman with the same hair
as hair is enough to set him off he can
instantly get lost in a daydream
Imagining the life she should have had
and this is why he's so dead set on
saving Ellie she's a new channel sense
the life that he and Sarah should have
had together and it's all that he cares
about Joel very much represents an
individual's needs and how one can
justify putting themselves above all
else now throughout the HBO podcast show
they've constantly talked about how love
is a theme in the series Angel
represents the positives and negatives
of it when you love someone you can do
lots of great things however you can
also do bad things in order to keep that
love giola is an embodiment of this with
him murdering an entire group of people
who in their hearts just wanted to save
Humanity on paper Joel is the bad guy
and when people are discussing the game
they'll always be the idea that when
you're playing as Joel you are playing
as the bad guy however the last of us is
never as black and white as that and
because we played as him we can
completely see things from his point of
view like him we've grown a bond with
Ellie and therefore we want to save her
and right off into the sunset now he
lies to Ellie not only for himself but
because he doesn't want to destroy the
image he has of his self and himself in
her eyes it's important to bear in mind
that Ali carries a lot of survivor's
guilt and this is due to the deaths that
she's seen happen Riley Tess Henry and
Sam all died whilst she lived and would
crush her further learning exactly what
Joel did in the end she's also
concerning to this idea too as she
accepts his version of events even
though they sound suspect they are both
living this lie with each other in which
they can go off and be father and
daughter together even though they
probably know that things aren't that
cut and dry they have to constantly keep
lying to themselves because the truth's
too difficult to face up to and Ellie
saying okay carries a lot with it it's
not an acceptance that that's what
actually happened it's an acceptance of
Joel's version of it and deep down Ellie
might even know that something bad could
have happened which he was spared from
now on the other side of this is Marlene
and she's very much the antithesis to
Joel in both ideology and personality
whereas he was someone who tried to keep
himself to himself Marlene did the
opposite she actively saw people out in
order to build the following and as the
leader of the fireflies she's rallied
hundreds to her cause oppressed by
Federer these down beaten and Overlook
people have managed to escape the
confines of fascism that they were
subjected to and though they're labeled
as terrorists they can also be seen as
Freedom Fighters Marlene sees Ellie is a
way to lead Humanity out of the darkness
and into the light much like how Jill
does however whereas that's for his
personal life Moline sees a being as
something that can help Humanity as a
whole creating a vaccine will stop the
grip the cordyceps have on the planet
and it means that the species can
finally recover this entire part of
human history could be looked back on
like how we look at the black death and
in hundreds of years time it's possible
that we could at least get back to where
we were Moline sees his potential and
she believes that the fireflies will
distribute the vaccine fairly she thinks
that Federer would hold people to Ransom
because again fascists whereas the
fireflies having it would be for the
better but is that really the case well
I actually think that's pretty unlikely
Kathleen is the perfect example of what
happens when Pedra are overthrown and
the alternative is often just as bad I
feel like the fireflies would be like
this too as their happy to bomb
civilians and create Warfare in order to
get their point across Marlene's heart
is in the right place but whether things
actually happened the way she imagined
is pretty unlikely what would probably
happen is that the fireflies would
require people to join them in order to
get the Cure and then there'd be a power
struggle now you shouldn't judge a book
by its cover but but I also don't think
that the fireflies have the facilities
to mass produce a vaccine if we look at
our own world there were shortages in
them after the pandemic and that was
with the worldwide effort to create them
so I don't really think that the
fireflies would be able to carry this
out either and in the waiting times
people would get frustrated those in
federal camps would likely hear of the
Cure and then tensions would start to
flare us better try to keep them in
check whilst the fireflies spread it
this would also take a while well and
likely cause further conflict in the
zones leading to more deaths people
would start to eat themselves just to
get a hold of this thing and the
fireflies could run out of resources
when trying to mass produce it fedra
could also spread misinformation and say
that the Cure doesn't actually work and
then they may rally people to their
cause which would cause further fighting
in war so lots of things to think about
however Marlene's hot in the right place
even if things aren't practical where
the Marley gray area comes from though
is whether it's okay to kill a child in
order to do this Marlene is alright
killing someone else's kid to do it but
whether she would do it for her own
child is something else entirely if
you're a parent then ask yourself right
now would you kill your own child to
give a group like the fireflies the
chance to produce a cure personally I
don't think that many would and I know
for a fact that if it came down to In
the Heat of the Moment that I'd say no
this is something that really struck me
when making this video as over the years
I've often been someone who was rooted
solely in the idea that Joel was in the
wrong I was an idealist who thought that
the ends Justified the means and that
killing one person was worth it in my
head I was Marlene making the tough
choice in order to carry out the greater
good sure had played as Joel and even
though I could definitely see things
from his point of view I thought that he
was the bad guy however since having
children myself I've now began to ask
myself would I hand them over like this
knowing that they'd die just so that the
fireflies could carry out their goals
and I don't think I could add to this
fact that Joel's already gone through
something like this and I really start
to see why he did what he did this is a
man who's already lost his daughter and
faced with the prospect of losing
someone else he cares about he simply
refuses to do it again knowing all of
this though I presented it as there
being two sides the one person that we
haven't talked about is Ellie they make
a big point in the finale of talking
about what she would have wanted and I
think it's important to discuss that too
using the ending as hindsight it seems
like she's just happy to go along with
whatever Joel tells her however part 2
does expand on her feelings quite a lot
in that she goes to Saint Mary's
Hospital herself and discovers the truth
about what really went down there
horrified she decides to cut Joel out of
her life and later on we learn that
she's devastated her life could have
meant so something in this moment we see
that Ali was happy to die if it meant
that a cure could be manufactured she
wanted all the deaths that happened to
get her to the hospital to mean
something but because of Joel's actions
they no longer did I think Joel knows
this too which is why he decides to lie
in the end he knows it will break out
his heart and is doing this to spare
himself even more than he's trying to
spare her so in the end I think that if
we look at this as being black and white
and yes Joel is in the wrong he went
against Ellie's wishes and also doomed
Humanity to eventual Extinction the
species in the show is on its last legs
and being pushed further down this road
will only lead to more deaths and also
division there's a reason that all of
the kids in the game outside of Ellie
end up dead and that's because it's near
impossible for a child to make it to
adulthood in this world so the species
will die eventually due to kids not
growing old enough to have them
themselves and will slowly dwindle into
Oblivion therefore I think that when
looked at like this a Joel is in the
wrong but and it's a big but as a father
I can also see why he did the right
thing and honestly if I was in the same
position I'd probably do that too we
would like to think that we are Marlene
but when pushed into a situation like
this imagine that most people will react
exactly the same whether it's your
mother father grandparents sister
brother or child when it comes down to
making that choice it's impossible to
say you'd happily hand them over so I
can totally see why Joel did what he did
and why I think I do the same thing
going back to the question of whether
Joel is right or wrong well I honestly
can't say though I'm like 90 80s let's
say 70 sure he was wrong because of what
we discussed there's still a little bit
of that in my mind and that might be
enough to make me side with Joel I think
when we think about this situation
theoretically that we as people would
all like to believe that we do it for
the greater good however if it actually
happened and I was forced to make the
choice between my kids and helping out
these I think I know deep down
exactly what I do now as many of you
know I get sent stuff early and I
actually wrote and recorded this video
before the finale aired and after
listening to the podcast I decided to
hold off the release so we could go and
add this extra bit in about what the
showrunner said they actually bring up
some of the points that I did about
being a parrot and also give their
thoughts on the choice at the end
and people have been debating the end of
The Last of Us since it came out 10
years ago and I can only assume that
people are debating it now I know we
sound innocent because we haven't gotten
there yet there may be riots in the
streets
but people will debate this and people
may look to this podcast for some sort
of answer and an answer will not be
forthcoming because the truth is you can
make an excellent argument either way
well we debate it even like as we were
working on we were debating it whether
like it's the right thing or not then
it's beyond right or not it comes down
to
there is an instinct within all of us to
do it this way and there's an instinct
within all of us to do it this way and
there's a lot of discourse about that
tries to rationalize why one decision
would be better than another and I have
no problem with people engaging it it's
kind of fun to do as a party game
but the reality is
it's a dilemma and the point of a
dilemma is it ain't easy and there isn't
one right answer and I can make an
outstanding argument that Joel should
have done exactly what he did and said
exactly what he said to Ellie after and
I can make an outstanding argument that
he shouldn't have done any of that and
that's kind of the point
that
as flawed human beings this is one of
the prices we pay for loving people
loving people
tends to Trump simple morality
and that's where Joel finds himself with
Ellie well yeah intellectually you can
make the argument this choice would save
the most people yes but this is not an
intellectual exercise when you're a
parent just a quick anecdote because
when I was working on the story of The
Last of Us I was talking with my dad you
know we're from Israel so seeped in
Israeli politics
there was this guy that was kidnapped an
Israeli soldier
he was held hostage for several years
and to get him back Israel traded
hundreds of prisoners in return
some of which I were tried for like
pretty horrible crimes so I asked my dad
like do you think they did the right
thing
and my dad goes are you asking me as the
prime minister of Israel or is the kid's
father because I could give you two very
different answers as the prime minister
of Israel I think it was a mistake they
made Israel weaker as the kid's dad I
would have traded the entire country for
my son and that is sort of what it comes
down to what was was fun is when we were
making the game we would um play test
the game and usually we do that to make
sure like people aren't getting stuck
and what we're trying to convey needs to
convey and then at the end one of the
questions we would ask if they finished
the game like what did you think of
Joel's choice in this moment
if the player was not a parent it was 50
50 whether they like they say oh I think
Joel was the villain that was the twist
or like no I totally agree with what he
did if the player was a parent a hundred
percent with zero exceptions they agreed
with Joel yeah zero exceptions now I
think the most important thing to bear
in mind is that Jill saved Ellie but in
many ways Ali saved Joel he's not gonna
abandon her to die even if we think that
he should because he's acting like a
parent who thinks he knows best but
there's still a cost that comes with us
and shows that no decision is without
its consequences so it's a Marley gray
area in which sadly there's no right or
wrong answer and I think that's what
gives the ending of The Last of Us it's
staying power we can argue over it
forever and really go back and forth
over what we would do so that's what I'm
gonna let happen yeah in the comments
below I'd love to hear your thoughts on
the ending so make sure you let me know
if you enjoy the video please hit the
thumb bit any climactic end of the video
but if you eventually join it please hit
the Thumbs Up Button make sure you
subscribe as we're doing more Last of Us
coverage over the next couple of weeks
we're also running in competition right
now giving away the rocky 4K box set to
three subscribers on the 15th of March
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the video we pick the
comments at random on the 15th and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers now if
you want some ballots to watch we've got
another hotly debated topic can we
forgive Abby if you've played the second
game you know exactly what I'm talking
about if you want to see that debated
then head over there right after this by
the way thanks for clicking the video
I've been four I'll see you next time
take care peace